i'm not sure if i've ever said this
before but i'm not a big fan of the
public school system maybe i've
mentioned that perhaps you've picked up
on that in the past i may have mentioned
it or time or two on second thought and
and for good reason there are about 70
million kids in our country
give or take and 50 million of them are
in public school so there's no other
institution that claims this kind of a
hold on this many kids almost all of
them 70 at least
as a society we have trusted this
institution
to mold entire generations of americans
to to determine what they believe what
they think what values they hold
we we've really handed our country over
to it over to this institution the
public school system and said here you
know you you
make our country into whatever you want
it to be this is this is totally up to
you
and we're suffering the consequences of
that decision but even now
many americans like to imagine that they
send their kids to public school only
for academic enrichment and training
only to learn the facts about you know
math and history and so on
but the system considers facts to be
secondary to its primary goal which is
to instill
values uh it's not so much to tell kids
about the world
but to control how
the kids see the world and how they feel
about what they see
the indoctrination the point here is the
indoctrination is not it's not a
byproduct
it's not a side effect
but it is indeed the point
of the system it's why the system exists
so that the state can form the younger
generations into whatever shape it
prefers it's not a conspiracy theory
that is why public school came into
existence for that reason
so that the state would have control
over
the next generation and over molding the
country and if you listen very closely
to the people
who run the system
you'll hear them admitting to this fact
and actually you don't even have to
listen that closely because they
practically will shout it into a
bullhorn at this point so take this for
example this is a profile in la magazine
of cecily meyer cruz who is the head of
the los angeles teachers union
here's the second paragraph
like i said shouting into a bullhorn you
don't have to listen even that closely
but this is where the second paragraph
of that profile says on a sun on a sunny
may afternoon my art cruise is allowing
a reporter inside her inner sanctum or
at least inside a glass-paneled
conference room down the hall from her
11th floor office and right away
she lives up to her reputation after
settling into a swivel chair and slowly
removing her zebra print face mask the
47 year old lightning rod for
controversy calmly sets her hands on the
table and begins issuing a series of
incendiary statements that almost seem
aerodynamically designed to grab
headlines and infuriate critics like
this one
quote
there is no such thing as learning loss
she responds when asked how about her
insistence on keeping la schools mostly
locked down over the last year and a
half and how that may have impacted the
city's 600 000 kindergarten through 12th
grade students
quote uh our kids didn't lose anything
it's okay that our babies may not have
learned all their timetables they
learned resilience they learned survival
they learned critical thinking skills
they know the difference between a riot
and a protest
they know the words insurrection and
coup
she even went so far as to suggest
darkly that learning loss is a fake
crisis marketed by shadowy purveyors of
clinical and classroom assessments
yeah it's a
learning loss is a conspiracy theory
she's saying
now she's right
in one sense that there is no reason why
kids
should suffer learning loss just because
public school has been shut down
so that teachers can have an 18-month
paid vacation
some parents picked up homeschooling
during that time and discovered that
their kids were learning more
than they ever had before
real learning begins
when you take your kids out of the
system that's when the best learning
real learning happens but unfortunately
many parents didn't replace public
school with homeschool they instead
plopped their kids down in front of
computers for seven hours a day hoping
that their eight and nine year olds
would learn from zoom classes
just put their you know put your
nine-year-old in a zoom meeting all day
and hope that he picked something up and
they didn't pick anything up nothing
absorbed
because nobody can really learn that way
or very few people can and especially
kids can't for many kids therefore
public school was replaced with uh with
nothing
which admittedly
still might be an improvement
but that's not the point that miss cruz
is trying to make she's saying that it
doesn't matter if our kids
our babies she says and she does mean
our as in like mine
um but it doesn't matter if they didn't
learn academic subjects because she says
they were still exposed to the right
political messages
they learned that when blm burns down a
city block
it's a protest but when people with maga
hats on riot it's an insurrection
and as far as she's concerned you know
if that's all they learned in 18 months
well that's good enough
right wing bad left wing good
that after all is the main thing i mean
it's the only thing she wants kids to
learn through 12 years of grade school
in fact the kids who learned the
difference between a riot and a protest
quote unquote are probably ready to
graduate as far as she's concerned no
need for them to finish fourth grade
just send them all the way through
because for her again the indoctrination
is the point here's another example if
you need it a teacher named kristen
pitzen posted some videos which have
since gone viral
where she brags about how she took the
american flag down in her classroom and
now tells her students to pledge
allegiance to the pride flag
now this teacher after intense backlash
from the public has apparently been
removed from the class though they're
not saying she was fired
permanently they're just saying she's
not teaching the classroom right now and
keep in mind
and that's good you know that she's not
in the classroom she should be fired
this this is this is a time when someone
should be canceled
and there are a lot of people on the
left reacting to this oh i thought you
guys were against cancel culture
no you you misunderstand i'm not against
people suffering consequences the the
correct consequences for bad actions
but that's not what cancer culture is
uh but keep in mind she was quote
unquote cancelled maybe
but only because she admitted to this
and posted it to tiktok
and then only because the account libs
of tiktok on twitter took it and put it
on twitter and then it went viral that's
the only reason she's suffering
consequences
if she had just kept this to herself or
just posted it to her own tik tok page
and not and it hadn't gone anywhere else
she would still be in the classroom
right now
so that's all the backgrounds
and uh here's the video watch this okay
so during third period we have
announcements and they do the pledge of
allegiance i always tell my class
stand if you feel like it don't stand if
you feel like it say the words if you
want don't have to say the words so my
class decided to stand but not say the
words totally fine except for the fact
that my room does not have a flag it
used to be there but i took it down
during covid
because it made me uncomfortable and um
i packed it away and i don't know where
and i haven't found it yet
but my kid today goes hey um it's kind
of weird that we just stand and then you
know we say it to nothing and i'm like
oh well you know i gotta find it like
i'm working on it i got you
in the meantime i tell this kid
we do have a flag in the class that you
can
pledge your allegiance to and he like
looks around he goes
oh that one
hilarious but the american flag makes
her uncomfortable
doesn't bother explaining why we're just
supposed to understand why it makes her
uncomfortable
and hey if you're uncomfortable with the
american flag you don't like this
country
we'll join the join the club with all
the other people that are that are in
your boat
and um maybe actually get on a boat and
go go somewhere else in fact i hear
kabul is nice this time of year why
don't you go there
if you're if
if you hate america so much that you're
uncomfortable around the flag
this kind of sentiment is would be
inconceivable in almost any other
country
in the world especially in the
non-western world
to have someone professing to be
uncomfortable around their own nation's
flag
but we not only have people who feel
that way here but they're teaching
students
and that wasn't the only video there's
another one too here she is talking
about all the pride flags in her
classroom and she's got about a million
of them it seems but uh here's that
it's pride month
it'll never not be awkward that's fun
for me happy pride everyone it's june
1st the start of pride month here's what
i got going in my classroom i got these
flags from target in like the dollar bin
so that's amazing
um they didn't have all of them in the
collection that they came out with so i
got all the ones they had
as well as the
inclusive
pride flag
i pledge allegiance to the queers
i also got a really big pride inclusive
ah flag um i need to put it up still but
it's gonna go up there and i need like a
ladder
so that's gonna come later but it's here
yay so i love you all very much for the
people who are out for the people who
aren't out you're appreciated you're
loved you are enough i support you i got
you
now think about the culture in that
school
and among the faculty
that made kristen pitzen think that uh
it was it was okay not only to do what
she did but to brag about it on the
internet
think about what's happening in that
school think about what's happening in
the faculty lounges what kind of
conversations are going on
that she was able to do that and and of
course
again if she hadn't posted this to tic
toc and then if it hadn't been picked up
on twitter and gone viral there'd be no
consequences at all
and if it wasn't for the american flag
but the fact that she's draping her
entire classroom
in pride flags that's not a problem at
all
she wouldn't get in any trouble for that
even though we're told we got to keep
religion and school separate
separate church and state
and this is that's her church that's her
that's a her religious symbol
that is analogous to
only a sense of being a religion is
analogous but it is like
a christian teacher
putting the crucifix up in the public
school classroom i guarantee if they did
that there'd be a lot of problems they'd
get sued for it and they get
fired why because it's a religious
symbol
now
does the constitution actually forbid
people at public school
teachers from expressing their religious
views i don't actually think it does
but that's the precedent that's what the
left always says
and the pride flags are your religious
devotion that is your that is your
church that's your religion that you're
hanging in the classroom
but that would be okay
if not for all the other bits and the
fact that it went viral
this we always have to remind ourselves
when we see this
this is not an aberration this is not an
exception
this is the point of the public school
system
things aren't going wrong here this is
the public school system doing exactly
what it's supposed to do
which is why you know what i'm going to
say to end this off to end this
get your kids out of that system
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content